la première ministre dit qu'il y a du
travail encore à faire que le compte n'y
est pas qu'elle va pouvoir travailler
avec vous c'est une main tendue
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez et sur
quel sujet vous voulez absolument
travailler aujourd'hui euh avec le
gouvernement pour la sécurité des maires
alors d'abord effectivement euh c'est
quand même pour nous une satisfaction de
voir que nos alertes sont prises au
sérieux que nos constats ne sont pas
contestés parce que les ça a été du
travail quand même hein de de faire
prendre conscience de cette situation
euh il y a un travail commun qui est
mené avec le gouvernement depuis
plusieurs semaines il doit se traduire
en acte en acte législatif dans un
premier temps et des annonces ont été
faites en la matière et nous nous en
réjouissons et ensuite comme toutes les
victimes parce que les mes ce sont des
victimes comme tous les autres Français
qui sont agressés qu'il y aura la
problématique des moyens dans les
parquets et c'est ça d'ailleurs c'est ce
que j'ai évoqué dans mon propos les
textes vont être là mais maintenant il
faut encore avoir les moyens il faut pas
il s'agit pas du tout de faire la fine
bouche c'est bien que les textes soi là
c'est bien qu' une prise de conscience
mais la réalité c'est que tant que
l'État ne sera pas
réformé dans sa façon de travailler on
sera toujours dans ce dilemme d'un État
à la fois surendetté qui doit baisser
ses dépenses et de services régaliens
qui eux-même sont sous-dotés donc c'est
tout le paradoxe mais en toute hypothèse
aujourd'hui la première ministre
manifestement a pris très au sérieux
l'Association des maires de France les
attentes des maires de France et nos
propositions donc je il faut s'en
réjouir